From philosophers and historians, to poets and
scientists alike, love has captured our
imagination and curiosity for centuries.
Many have experienced the rush of falling in
love for the first time.  Or the deep
feelings of love for your children,
family and friends.  But what is love from
a biological perspective?  No doubt it's
intertwined with the evolutionary
survival of our species.  Afterall you
come from an unbroken line of organisms
reproducing from the very first microbe
that split in two, to your ancestors who have all
successfully mated since the dawn of
time.
Sadly, if you fail to have children this
perfect streak comes to a halt.
But while we're driven to reproduce, we're also
driven to make sure our offspring
survive.
Though we often associate love with the
heart, of the true magic can be seen
inside the brain.
It may not be entirely surprising to
find out that the brain of somebody in
love looks awfully similar to one on cocaine.  Cocaine acts on the pleasure
centers in the brain by lowering the
threshold at which they fire.  This means
that you feel really good alot easier.
We see the same thing in the brains of
those in love, but it's not just the
cocaine or the love that makes you feel
good it's the fact that anything you
experience will now more easily set off
pleasure centers and make you feel good.
Because of this you not only fall in
love with the person, but begin to build a
romanticized view of the world around
you.  Interestingly nearby pain and
aversion centers begin to fire less,
so you become less bothered by things.
Simply put we love being in love.
So what chemicals are at work to make all of
this happen?  Both during orgasm or by
simply looking at photos of a loved one,
there is a surge of dopamine and
norepinephrine from the ventral tegmental area.
This not only triggers sexual arousal in
your racing heart, but gives you the
motivation craving and desire to be with
a person more and more.  You see romantic
love is not simply an emotion, it is a drive
from the motor of the mind.  And this
motor brings about intense energy
focused attention and elation.  The
pleasure centers are part of the brains
reward system.  The mesolimbic dopamine
system.  If you stimulate this region
while learning, learning becomes much
easier because it's pleasurable and
perceived as a reward.
We also see a surge in the neuromodulator oxytocin from the
nucleus accumbens.  Sometimes called the
"commitment neuromodulator" because in mammals it helps to reinforce bonding or
attachment.  When prairie voles are
injected with either oxytocin or
vasopressin they will instantly find a mate to
pair a bond with.  Finally, studies have
shown that people in love have low
levels of serotonin.
Which is similar to people with
obsessive-compulsive disorder.
This is likely cause of our obsession
and infatuation during early love.
Amazingly, these areas associated with
intense romantic love can remain active
for decades, and while there are many
other physiological and psychological
components that add to the mix, the truth
is, science still knows very little about
exactly why or how love works.  And yet
somehow, we all seem to know it when we
feel it.
Gott a burning question you want answered? Ask it in the comments, or on facebook and twitter.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos.